thank you uh good afternoon everyone
this morning as was stated the united
states supreme court heard oral
arguments
on the case of grave importance to the
american people
this case represents the latest attempt
by the far-right ideologues to do what
they've been repeatedly failed to do
for a long time in the courts in the
congress and the court of public opinion
over the last decade to eliminate the
entirety of the affordable care act
twice
already the supreme court has upheld the
landmark law
in 2012 and again in 2015.
and the congress expressing the popular
will of the american people on a
bipartisan basis
has rejected numerous attempts numerous
efforts by president trump
to erase the law as well now in the
middle of a deadly pandemic
that has infected more than 10 million
americans
nearly one in every 32 americans
often with devastating consequences to
their health
these ideologues are once again trying
to strip
health coverage away from the american
people the goal
of the outgoing administration is clear
from the brief they filed in the supreme
court
it asserts and i quote the entire aca
thus must fall end of quote
now i'm not naive about the fact that
health care is an issue that has divided
americans in the past
but the truth is the american people are
more united on this issue today than
they are divided
recently as last month the leading
survey found that american people want
to keep the affordable care act in place
by an overwhelming margin of 58 percent
to 36 percent
79 percent of the american people
including 9 out of 10 democrats
8 out of 10 independents and two-thirds
of republicans
want to keep the aca protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
which would be eliminated if this
lawsuit were to succeed
this doesn't need to be a partisan issue
it's a human issue it affects every
single american family
we can't subvert the growing consensus
the american people
based on an argument put forward in the
briefs seeking to invalidate the law
that even many conservative legal
scholars including in the national
review consider to be quote
ridiculous let's be absolutely clear
about what's at stake
the consequences of the trump
administration's argument are not
academic or an abstraction
for many americans they are a matter of
life and death in a literal sense
this argument will determine whether
health care coverage of more than 20
million americans who acquired an earned
affordable care act
will be ripped away in the middle of the
nation's worst pandemic
in a century over 100 million people as
the vice president-elect
pointed out over 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions
like asthma diabetes cancer could once
again be
denied coverage whether complications
from
covert 19 like lung scarring and heart
damage
will be the next flood of pre-existing
conditions that could be used as an
excuse to jack up premiums
or deny coverage altogether for millions
of survivors
who have struggled won and fought
the co the coronavirus fought against
the loss of their life
this argument is going to determine
whether women as has pointed out
will once again be charged higher
premiums just because they're women
or seniors will see their prescription
drug costs
go up and like kids who
whether or not they can stay on their
parents plan solay's 26
where their annual lifetime benefits
will be
reimposed so someone could walk in and
say
die in peace you run out of your
coverage
it's in hyperbole it's real as real as
it gets
when the family is faced with the awful
news of a child's diagnosis with
leukemia
or a mom forced to battle against breast
cancer
an accident that leaves loved ones
unable to live the life
they've always known it stops your heart
it stops your heart it
wrenches your entire world right off its
axis when that happens
and many of you know that from your own
personal experiences
believe me i know the feeling and too
many american families do as well
in that moment the very last thing on
your mind
the very last thing should be on your
mind is whether you can afford the
treatment
a ford affordable care act was created
to put a stop
to that in humanity it was created to
ensure that families
thrust into their worst nightmare of
their lives could focus
not only not on money but on the fight
that really matters
obamacare is a law that every american
should be proud of
it's why people with pre-existing
conditions are protected in this country
it's a law that delivered vital coverage
as i said before for 20 million
americans
who did not have coverage it's a law
that reduced prescription drug price
costs
for nearly 12 million seniors
it's a law that saved lives and spared
countless families from financial ruin
so this effort to bypass
the will of the american people the
verdict of the courts in the past the
judgments of congress
in my view is simply cruel and
needlessly divisive
regardless of the outcome of this case i
promise you this
beginning on january 20th the vice
president-elect harris and i
we're going to do everything in our
power to ease the burden of health care
on you
and your families i promise you that as
i said i will protect your health care
like i protect
like as with my own family and we've
been unfortunately
significant consumers of health care
that starts by building on the
affordable care act
with the dramatic expansion of health
care coverage
and bold steps to lower health care
costs
my transition team will soon be starting
its work
to flesh out the details so that we can
hit the ground running
tackling costs increasing access
lowering the price of prescription drugs
families are reeling right now
particularly the reporters in this room
and others listening you've interviewed
a lot of these people
around the country as you've gone all
over the world all over the country
enduring illnesses faced with risky
choices losing their
employer plans and droves already 10
million have already lost their employer
plans
they need a lifeline and they need it
now
they should have to hold their breath
they shouldn't be in that position
waiting to see if the supreme court is
going to
wrench away the peace of mind
they've come to now rely on
so we're going to get right to work i
promise you
addressing the issues that families are
are talking about around the kitchen
tables this morning
making sure that they can get bed
tonight with the peace of mind that they
deserve
and fulfilling our moral obligation to
ensure that here in america healthcare
is a right for
all not a privilege for a few
so come january we're going to work
quickly with the congress to
dramatically ramp up health care
protections
get americans universal coverage lower
health care costs
as soon as humanly possible
that's the promise i make to you we're
going to fight
for your family's health coverage the
same way we fight for our own family's
health coverage
we want every single american to know if
you're sick
if you're struggling if you're worried
about how you're going to
get going to get through the day we will
not abandon you that is a promise
will not leave you to face these
challenges alone
we're going to get through this we're
going to get through it together
and we're going to build a health care
system that puts you and your families
first
and that every american can be proud of
i want to thank you all for listening
may god bless you may god keep you safe
in this coveted environment
and may god protect our troops